all right let's check out this video i
thought this was pretty good
so 15 20 seconds in you're seeing cowboy
cerrone who was the bigger guy
right okay the bigger guy coming into
this fight be done in like 15 to 20
seconds
i mean i don't think he landed a single
blow against conor mcgregor it was like
shadow fighting for crying out loud
look i have gotten hit that much in the
last week here's what i'm thinking the
lights might have been too bright joe
those bright lights shine down upon you
and you just ain't ready
no matter how much experience you have
you just ain't ready
and that's how it looked tonight cowboy
cerrone just didn't look ready you
didn't learn anything from tonight's
fight
because cowboy cerrone just didn't
show up i could have ran for 40 seconds
i disagree
here i'm standing next to a legend okay
him putting his arm on him
was really awkward right and far be it
for me to refute anything that joe rogan
says but here's my reality
we haven't learned a damn thing about
conor mcgregor baseball for this fight
because who were you listen the king
trip made this by the way to plug
it did not get hit if you're done in 15
seconds my lord you couldn't back up
cowboy cerrone you couldn't
catch it the hand on the shoulder thing
is making me uncomfortable
circle the octagon just a little bit get
your bearings on you you couldn't do
anything
40 seconds there was not a challenge
there was not a challenge
maybe even conor mcgregor
[Music]
play play this jamie watch this
first of all someone needs to explain me
what's happening here
well it looks like i'm just punched to
the left look how low he's punching
this guy should not be allowed to talk
about fighting he would
oh no beat the holy hell out of a
toddler look at this here
like there's a toddler there bunch of
time right in the forehead right there
toddler right in the forehead right
there
me steven a smith me being
at the conor mcgregor fight check the
numbers
the level of attention that it got the
traffic that it generated in digital and
beyond
now royce i don't know if you know but
it's true
they say that the mcgregor fight
the conor mcgregor fight that uh
it benefited from what they call the the
steven a smith bump
mcgregor personally thanked stephen a
smith and was like hey man thanks for
coming and helping me out
because i really needed the help because
people don't really watch conor mcgregor
fights
but he people don't really go nuts when
them
mcgregor fights he doesn't he
he thinks that yes that he's he knows
the biggest fighter in the world he
thinks that
yeah it was him you think he does it
[Laughter]
one of the funniest things jay farrow
did because jfro used to play steven a
smith so great he goes
lebron and i go to the same hairline
doctor that was funny
[ __ ] great check the numbers
number one you called a guy a quitter
first of all he had a broken orbital
bone
okay you saying he was a quitter he got
his face smashed yeah okay hey
rogan but why don't you tell him when he
was like they're with you
not that i think rogan's afraid of
stephen a smith but you should have
[ __ ]
you should have roasted yeah but he was
you know yeah he was you know what was
on espn it wasn't his turn 50 million
people watching
like this right right okay and that's a
scenario too where i think people
you kind of know we're on tv right i
know this guy's
actually making an ass of himself right
now so sometimes
it's just best to not get dragged into
it and also look like an ass
so joe was probably like yeah yeah
yeah get me out of here guy a quitter
first of all he had a broken orbital
bone
okay you're saying he was a quitter he
got his face smashed yeah okay
it don't take much to look at three
shoulder shots to the nose
that conor mcgregor gave cowboy cerrone
watching him fold inside of 20 seconds
knowing that he only got one strike off
and oh by the way that was blocked by
connor
that's why you need guys like you
doing post fight commentary and
discussing these
not people who don't understand the
sport and practice dick punches well i
would
dude george is beefing is he beefing
with stephen a smith
are they beefing he doesn't like steven
a smith too much
he's basically he's hitting babies
excuse me
what are we talking about here yeah and
when someone calls you a quitter like
that you better be
i'm not saying he should be careful like
watch his back but don't expect these
fighters to be very courteous to you
next time you walk in the hall
but anytime you want to talk to me about
this fight or you want to talk to me
about my credentials to discuss
something
in a world of sports name the time and
place joe rogan i'll show up
[Music]
um there was a reason like one of the
greatest commentators of all time john
madden didn't talk about baseball
like it's a niche thing like you know
your thing right
they would bring in they would bring in
guys like madden once in a while at a
thing
because it would be like a star-studded
playoff game and they'd bring them in
for like two things and you know what
guys like bad needs to do
so what'd you think john what'd you
think uh you know yankees mets huh
subway series what do you think
i think it's a heck of a game right
isn't that what you'd always do when
they would bring
or they bring an nfl guy they bring an
nba guy over to an nfl game
what'd you think of that first quarter
huh oh man i think both teams are just
really playing really hard today good
game
they just they don't come in and start
go man these [ __ ] they don't know
what they're doing
you know stephen a smith and skip
bayless used to have a show i forgot
what it was called but that was there
was one of the biggest shows
espn had right because there was two
boobs arguing
right and it was two boobs taking the
opposite sides of things and somehow
both
being wrong because fox sports gave him
just a backed up a truck of money and
they said we want you
so stephen a smith stayed there skip
bayless went to fox and
when the little divorce happened i
always
goofed on sk i still to the stage goof
on skip bayless i think skip basis
he's easy to goof on he makes it easy
skip bayless is this guy that rides on
his high horse but he's the one that
when he was a writer for a dallas
newspaper started the rumor that troy
aikman was gay like
for nothing and he fragments life was
like i'm
dude i'm not gay like what are you doing
ruined his [ __ ] it's a [ __ ]
such a high school level move to pull on
somebody you know i heard he's gay right
guys but right now holy [ __ ] stephen a
smith you look like a
fool he looks like a dare i say royce he
looks like a real boob
this is all good for him like the more
people talk [ __ ] about him better it is
for him
and then he just ramps it up even more
and more people are paying attention the
ratings go up
until he sees cowboy in an elevator
go ride a [ __ ] head buddy but
cowboy's not going to hit him either
like
he's going to do he's not going to hit
him is this how you want your sport to
be represented yeah i don't think that's
great like pretty sure dana white would
have a thing or two to say about it this
isn't ufc one where like they were just
fighting people in bars all the time
like
they would probably cowboy would
probably go hey man
what's up like you probably say
something but do you think cowboy is
gonna [ __ ] risk his next his next six
million dollar fight
over punching stephen a smith and
they're not gonna do that
come on who's quitting now [ __ ]
yeah but it's not the place for mma it's
just not the play it's not it's not the
same
thing it's it's not because um
because the guys themselves can fight
excuse me
what are we talking about here if he
said something like that about a nader
nick diaz and they saw him in a [ __ ]
elevator he would [ __ ] him up they would
[ __ ] him up legitimately
dude i'm gonna pop him if he gets near
me how about that
how about if he gets near him he's gonna
pop how about that all right so to be
fair
yes i will i will be i will be honest
here yeah guys
nader nick diaz would probably do that
but they're [ __ ] crazy they also had
yeah they they had they they probably i
want to be fair
they probably would yeah yeah excuse me
you're just wrong on this particular one
and i'm telling you you're wrong
because cowboy cerrone in his first
pay-per-view match
folded i respect him but he folded like
a cheap ten period
look there's a lot of reasons to make
fun of joe rogan right
i mean for example giving brandon shop a
career would be the first one that comes
to my mind
but joe rogan having such a frumpy
alleged side piece
yes but joe rogan
knows for mma like look you could say
whatever you want
you you agree right you give him cred
you have to get
that guy is a nerd when it comes to mma
like
he is a [ __ ] want to be doing it
forever he knows it
stephen a smith you're a [ __ ] when it
comes to mma and
actually except maybe basketball most
sports in general
you're an idiot joe rogan
if you need me but that's what i'm
saying him and skip had a show
he just this is a [ __ ]
what did he just do to rogan somebody
folded like a cheap 10 period
joe rogan if you need me you know
[Music]
you do that to another dude bro you just
think then he wants to fight because
here's the difference joe rogan
joe rogan doesn't have a first off joe
rogan's not going to fight anybody
second of all joe rogan doesn't need you
yeah he does it he doesn't need this
there's a link there's a link did he can
you imagine if like
that's like something joey gibson did to
you or like
you punch him in the face like what are
you doing
you're right i think he's just cloud
chasing and it's so weird
like i was saying him and skipped at a
show where
it's so rare when you watch a show where
both guys are opposite but they both are
always wrong well it's like our show
and then they're just boobs and then
they would just argue like our show
over yeah but over sports oh you're
right that's the difference
that we do with other things that's the
difference i just never understood the
sports shows because it's like i
understand arguing a little bit but
who the [ __ ] could you imagine arguing
for a half hour to an hour over one
sports topic